this is the avocado if but before I tell
you anything about it we have to talk
about Geordi LaForge if you watch Star
Trek The Next Generation you remember
geordi's visor right I mean you look at
this and you think of that and even
though this won't let you see through
your comrades jammies it really kind of
is tech from the future but the glyphs
made for people who travel a lot or
people who want to watch something
without disturbing somebody next to them
or people who just want a bigger
portable screen than their phone most of
all people who don't mind looking
completely ridiculous some day more
people might know what this is and they
won't look at you funny anymore but
right now nobody has any clue what this
thing is and they definitely looked at
me funny in the park it's like Google
glass only way Dumber looking honestly
more power to you if you're cool wearing
this thing on the subway I couldn't do
it I have been wearing it a lot at home
though just tech wise it's actually
pretty cool you put it on and instead of
looking at the screen it's what's called
a virtual retinal display it's light
bouncing off of tons of tiny mirrors and
directly into your eyes that's much more
like the way we see things in the world
and it's amazing how much more natural
it feels the display is actually way
better than most VR headsets but it is
absolutely not a VR headset there's none
of that screen door effect and it won't
make you sick once you get the focus
right it's just like looking at a window
but for something that was invented to
be worn on the go the glyph is just sort
of awkward
you have to tweak the lenses the focus
even the placement of the nose bridge I
don't think I ever got it perfectly and
you'd probably have to tweak it a little
every time you fire the thing up the
whole thing gets kind of warm on your
face too and it's just too heavy to wear
comfortably for more than about the
length of a movie I've been using the
glyph while washing dishes or cooking or
just lying in bed
I've played xbox on him I have listened
to music like it was just a pair of
headphones I've watched movies I've
heard of other people using it as a
first-person drone viewer it's not a
perfect product and then 699 bucks it's
a really expensive plaything I like it
it looks ridiculous but I like it I'm
just never wearing it outside